[Musique]
tu souffres,
ils ont perdu
[Musique
] Dieu les protège,
dieux de l'univers,
je viens ici pour lever une armée
aujourd'hui,
nous entrerons dans l'histoire à
quel point nous nous battrons aujourd'hui,
je suis  va tuer ce mec
ressemble probablement à un véridique
[Musique]
cela se termine ici et maintenant
je compte sur ces
studios marvel thor amour et tonnerre dans le
théâtre chill ia classé pg-13 billets
toujours disponibles
dieu du tonnerre roi khan tu as
enfin rejoint notre  se battre bien, disent-ils,
mieux vaut tard que pas du tout,
c'est très bien
car vous savez que nous vivions tous dans un
endroit paisible,
mais nos dieux ont été assassinés
et maintenant notre temple sacré a été laissé
sans surveillance et l'espoir a été dissous pour
contrôler son  pouvoir c'est notre
sanctuaire le plus sacré et il ne profane pas
longtemps,
vous ne pouvez pas
leur dire ce qui s'est passé ici aujourd'hui, donc à
l'époque où le
thor était hétéroclite, desperados inadaptés
renversent la vapeur dans la bataille et cela
prolonge les noms dans l'histoire, les chances peuvent  être
contre nous, mais je vais tél  l vous ceci
gratuitement ici nous allons ceci
et
ici et maintenant
vous